Jack root that door what are you doing
here
getting you out here put this on you'll
need it
Jack rip that door
what are you doing here
getting you out here put this on you'll
need it
you can get in a lot of trouble for
doing this not anymore
things have changed we better go what
about the other prisoners you can't just
leave them here they're gone
Hoffman pardon everybody is that right
they're gone
welcome back to the army soldier [ __ ]
get ready here they come
watch it
good to go
trendy right there over
over
we have a plan to end this war once and
for all
yeah right sensors computing of enemy
movements are close by
Lucas
we now have the light mass bomb I'll
take out all these bastards with one
shot but it can't work if we don't have
the targeting data that's why we need
the resonator it'll map their tunnels so
that we can hit those sons of [ __ ]
where they live now on this one else
with quorus last transmission
and deploy that resonator do we have air
support what are you kidding
you are the support son down to two new
verses are keeping our birds out of the
area you'll have to move in on foot
we're screwed
all clear
but the lieutenant here will be feeding
you Intel yes sir
and the smart thing to do right now
would be to leave you get it done I
expect you to give me 110 percent
Phoenix I'm not doing this for you
you